uh newly released department of justice
documents reveal how nelly or
a fusion gps transmitted material from
the trump dossier to her husband
uh senior doj official bruce orr
that information then of course filled
the federal government percolated all
the way through and was used to taint
the trump administration
with bogus insinuations of espionage
before
it had even been sworn in tom fitton is
the president
of judicial watch judicial watch
obtained those documents
uh and he joins us now tom this
uh nexus between one woman who's working
for a group
uh that's working for the clinton
campaign who happens to be married
to a senior figure in uh the government
this is basically
uh classic banana republic stuff because
it's the merger of the
party and the state as it were yeah
bruce wars telling the fbi
essentially hey i got this information
let's investigate the president
this is after president trump's elected
he brings in a flash drive with his
wife's material on it
stripped from that material is the
header the information fusion gps from
the headers
right so they were trying to disguise
the material we get that from the fbi
interview notes
and then we get this other batch of
documents that you're talking about
which describes the material
that orr is shepherding on behalf of his
wife and the clinton
operation to his colleagues at the fbi
and it includes a chart i mean
people have got to go look at this chart
because it's crazy it's about 80 names
and he she tries to tie all of them to
russia and to trump
it's like an insane version of six
degrees of kevin bacon
if you saw it on a wall somewhere and
you walked into a room with it on it you
say
who's the crazy person who created this
this was the basis
for the trump russia fraudulent
investigation and the fact that the
senior levels at the doj and the fbi
where using this material to target a
sitting president
uh tells you volumes about the
corruption behind the effort
uh to overthrow him this is the
kookaburra in its insane
form well let me let me ask you a very
simple question based on what you asked
for all the documents the communications
between
bruce ohr and uh this uh
mi6 agent british subject christopher
steele
after he'd been gotten rid of by the fbi
bruce ohr is still
palsy wellesley has there ever been
a u.s domestic election
process as interfered with by one
foreign national
as has been perpetrated by this british
spook
christopher steele i don't understand
why americans aren't mad about that
yeah i think there's an open question
about the involvement of his
former colleagues in the united kingdom
we have the australian government who
uh is being asked uncomfortable
questions about this as well this was an
international
uh uh conspiracy against the president
it's laid out in the fbi documents
or and steal or working together during
the campaign
after the campaign and magically they
hire orr's wife
the clinton campaign uh to to help
push material into the justice
department you got to hand it to the
clinton gang they had all their bases
covered
they were flooding the zone doj fbi
state and the wife of the senior justice
department
and and most of washington's five eyes
intelligence allies in on the scheme
it's an amazing thing keep keep digging
on this tom there's lots more
to come thank you very much for that